- Even if you work nine to five.
If you worked eight hours a day
and you sleep eight hours a day,
that means work is 50% of
every hour of your whole day.
For 40 years of your life.
Like, why the fuck are you
doing something you hate?
Make less money, buy less
fancy shit and be happy.
(hip hop music)
You've got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(R&B music)
- Huge day at ADHD 'cause I got my friend
Gary Vaynerchuk in the studio.
Dude, thank you so much for coming on,
I really appreciate it.
- You better thank mother nature.
- Yeah, (laughs) we were
talking before the mics cut on
and literally if it wasn't for a blizzard,
we wouldn't be doing this right now.
- That's right, so I was
supposed to be in Chicago today.
In LA tomorrow real quick,
before I go to Phoenix
but a lot of snow, so my admins adjusted.
They're like we're sending you to LA
first thing in the morning, I'm like cool
and I remembered that you reached out
and I was like I really
wanted to support you.
- [Travis] I appreciate that.
- And I was like, had slid into your DM,
got hot and slid into Tyler's--
- No, we literally did
everything via Instagram.
- Yeah.
- Which is so incredible
in the digital age,
but one thing about you,
man, is you don't only talk,
you don't only talk it, you walk it.
You know what I mean?
You give away things for free,
you build genuine connections with people
and you're a man of your
word and I think integrity
is something you don't come
across very often out here.
- You know what's crazy is,
it's mainly because I'm so
flattered, the fact that I know
that having me as a
guest gives you leverage
for the guests you get after this,
it makes me feel nice and
it's such a crazy feeling.
And I think that all of
us wanna put people on,
especially if we generally
have a vibe towards them,
and I think that I loved being the wiz kid
in the wine world and the tech world,
I loved being that wiz kid
as a 12 year old baseball card dealer,
but I just turned 43,
as now I'm going into that next chapter,
I remember being 25, 27 and worrying that
oh shit, one day I won't be the wiz kid
and am I gonna be sad?
But I'm super fired up to be Yoda.
- [Travis] (laughs) The OG.
- Yeah I haven't seen Creed 2 yet
but Rocky's in the corner
and I'm sure at some point
Rocky was like fuck, when
I'm not gonna be in the ring
is it gonna be as cool
but now he's getting his
high from training the next
generation and I think,
I'm not 70 yet but no question
because everybody's in it
so much younger these days,
I probably got to feel OG
a little bit earlier than I anticipated.
But yeah, at the end of the day,
also I gotta tell you,
having a good memory helps.
Literally getting a text from my admins
and being like, we're sending you to LA,
realizing I have nothing booked
because my day was planned in Chicago.
Plenty of things to do
but being able to be like
oh shit, he might be around
and having a good memory
has been a sneaky, I never talk about this
but so much of what I pull off,
is based on having a great memory.
- You know one thing
that I look to you for
in a big part of my journey,
in my career, in my life
is self-awareness and one
thing I wanted to say to you
is self-awareness is scary as fuck.
- If you're good at judging yourself.
I think self-awareness,
if you're capable of
accepting yourself for who you are
is actually the brightest light of it all.
I love being self-aware,
I such at a lot of things.
I just don't think about them.
Like, I can't read for shit!
I interrupt people when
I interview them 24/7
and everybody's super pissed
on the internet about that.
Not good!
'Cause I already know
what the person's saying,
I can't help it, I'm sorry.
There's plenty of things
that I'm not good at.
I love self-awareness.
It's kept me so happy.
I'm not upset at myself that
I'm selfish in certain areas.
That's human.
I think that we just
don't love each other,
ourselves enough.
I think we, I don't know whose
perfection I'm trying to live up to.
Like silly things, people get
on me for biting my nails.
Who gives a fuck?
(laughs)
People just critiquing
themselves all day long.
- You like reading the comments?
- Love!
- You do it on every video, every post?
- All day.
- How do you deal with the negativity?
Someone talking about biting your nails?
- Empathetic.
Empathy.
Somebody just watched 49 seconds of me
spitting some pontification on Instagram
and they've decided to
make a judgment on me.
And I respect that, I
put myself out there.
They don't know everything about me,
so when they drag me down and be like,
this guy's a fucking idiot
or, he's full of shit
or, what the fuck or I'm
like, that makes sense,
they saw me in the Explore feature,
they're like who's this dick face?
They watch it, they don't like
it and they decide I'm shit
and they're not in a good place
so they have to drag down.
I deploy empathy first, sucks to be,
I would never do that as a
happy person to anybody else
so A, I'm already feel bad
and B, who the fuck am I?
They only got 49 seconds
and in 49 seconds at a time
I could suck shit in perpetuity.
(laughs)
You know, like at 49 seconds at a time
I could be all-time terrible,
especially me that gets hot
and competitive and like,
you know, like this is how I
am when the lights come on so
I deal with the negativity with empathy
to the person that's leaving the comment.
A, for the fact that I feel bad
because they're in a bad place
that they decided to put
more hate into the system
and B, like, they shouldn't
do seven hours of research
of my career or who I am as a human being.
I would be upset if you
thought I was a dick.
Because you've had enough interactions
at this point to have a read.
- Yeah.
- But like Rick in Arkansas or New York
who saw me in Explore
or who saw, by the way,
and I have a lot of empathy because
I also have fans and followers
and people that consume my
content that really give me love.
And you know the natural reaction,
when somebody's posting like,
this guy's a fuckin' genius,
you know, 30% of people
are like, fuck that guy,
before they even watched anything.
I get that, so, I mean,
I hated Tiger Woods and Kobe
and Shaq in their prime,
they weren't my guy.
So I have empathy, I put myself out there
and if you're putting yourself out there
you have to deal with the ramifications
of the reality of the system
so I respect the system,
I respect the market.
If you don't know who I am
and you think I'm the biggest
piece of shit, I'm great.
If you know who I am and
you think that I'm dead.
And that's how I live my life.
- Speaking of empathy,
you know, the reason why
we started talking last week
is you launched Empathy Wines.
Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- My mom's not gonna listen this podcast
so it's safe to say that I ordered her
a bunch of wine for Christmas.
- Thank you.
- Why Empathy Wine, why now?
- John Troutman and Nate Schroeder,
two guys that have worked
for me for a decade
graduated up the wine library
and VaynerMedia system
and we're getting to that
age where they were like,
hey, what's next for me?
Our capabilities to produce
content and marketing
to sell a product off the
back of the K-Swiss stuff
was obvious to me that it was very high.
I miss wine.
- I was gonna say, is it
almost like nostalgic for you--
- 100%, 100%
- To step back into this?
- I also knew I could do it.
I knew that I could produce
the best $40 wine in the world
and sell it for 20 bucks.
Like people are gonna
shit when they taste this.
- I can't wait to get
mine, like literally, yeah.
- Yeah, like the amount of Empathy Rose
that is gonna be on Instagram
this summer and spring,
I can't wait, from from Gunna to--
- Do you know who you
need to get some rose to,
my friend Shameik Moore, he's the voice
of Miles Martin, the new
Spider-Man movies coming out.
Anytime we go to dinner,
like we can go have lunch
at 12 or one, rose.
- Set that up before, done.
- I got you, I got you.
- So yeah, there was a lot of factors.
I was ready, I'm a timing
guy, I was ready to start
a project that was direct-to-consumer
on the back of internet marketing 2019
in a category that I was deeply
knowledgeable in, timing.
- And it's a subscription service.
- You can buy three, six, or 12 bottles
of each of the red,
the white, and the rose
and it's a subscription service.
Most people don't wanna think about wine,
people hate going to BevMo and Total Wine
and Costco and Wine Library,
like, you have to go.
And so once I convinced everybody
that I'm producing the
best $20 bottle of wine
I think it's gonna be a beast.
- Another thing I wanted
to bring up is Trash Talk.
It's probably one of my, it
is definitely my favorite
new GaryVee thing to watch,
it's so entertaining.
You're literally going
to people's garage sales,
you're buying things and
flipping them on eBay.
What made you wanna start doing this?
- It's become very obvious to
me that excuses are my poison
and I want to eliminate them at all costs.
I talk a lot about hustle
and hard work and people are
kind of pushing back on
me a little bit right now
and it's been interesting, I'm like,
man, I haven't done a
good enough job clarifying
that when I talk about work ethic
I'm trying to speak to people
who are unhappy or complaining.
Not happy with your job,
don't watch Netflix.
Work after hours, save money, quit.
I'm not trying to get people
into depression or burnout,
I'm trying to address unhappiness.
One of the things I saw
a lot in my comments,
'cause I read them all,
was well I have no money.
I'm like, fuck, I lived my
whole life with no money
but I figured it out,
I would just buy shit.
I would buy garage sales shit
and it just got me going, going,
I love it, it's like a hobby
of mine to go garage selling.
- I started doing that with clothes,
I used to do that with clothes.
- Dude, the amount guys,
especially like a stylish kid like you,
like if you have flavor, if
you're listening right now
and you don't have money but you're cool,
you got flavor, you got
swag, you got style,
if you just spend your life in
Goodwill and in thrift stores
and buy shit that you think is fresh
and then wear it and take a fucking selfie
and put it on eBay for
three times the price
or, like I see every day,
the amount of people that
buy three dollar t-shirts
and sell them for 35
bucks on eBay and Etsy
and fucking Facebook
marketplace is enormous.
There's no excuse in America
to say you have no money
even if you're in the
deepest poorest places
because if you can literally get a dollar
you can buy your first t-shirt at Goodwill
and get it up for 15 bucks on Facebook.
Because you know what's funny?
What's funny is everybody's
got a smartphone.
like you go into the
poorest places in America
and everybody's got a smartphone
which means you have the internet.
I mean listen, the homeless,
you've got people all over
on homeless smartphones.
I get emails every day, I'm homeless,
I watch you on YouTube.
You know, so I don't know, I really,
and listen, of course
there's 1% that don't and I,
that's what's always fascinating to me,
the 1% that populates
like, what about my aunt?
I'm like, cool, I get it,
but I'm trying to address
99.9% of people and the
garage sale thing's been huge.
By the way, huge, I have tens of thousands
of Tweets. Emails. DMs,
messages from people
over the last 100 days
who are completely inspired by the show
and are making significant money.
And significant comes in all forms.
Do you know what it's like
to make an extra 200 bucks a month
when you're not doing well financially?
- Huge, huge.
- Huge.
Huge, like it fucking matters.
It's also fun for 50% of people.
- Well I watch the videos
and I'm watching you like go
and you're getting, you're
picking up these stuffed animals
and you're like, do you know
what this is gonna sell for?
40 bucks, 50 bucks!
- And seven bucks I get pumped,
like I'm buying something for a quarter,
selling it for 11 on eBay,
with the fees, with all the bullshit
that everybody makes fun
of me in the comments for.
What about the gas, all that.
Like, I'm still like, I made six bucks.
I bought it for quarter, I
sold it for 11. net six bucks,
or I could be jerking
off of my couch right now
watching fucking Netflix.
Like, if you complain and you're unhappy
I will spend my career
suffocating the living shit out of you.
That is basically, and by the way,
out of gratitude and guilt.
I've come to realize this, I'm so grateful
for my DNA, my parenting,
my circumstance of growing up with nothing
and I feel a level of guilt.
I was so gifted a mother
that put me in a position to succeed,
I know that everybody has that.
So I'm almost trying
to play my parents role
for everybody that watches my content.
if you don't have that person in your life
let me be that shield,
let me populate you up.
You're either a person
that goes into comments
to drag people down or you're a person
that puts out content to put people up.
I'm so proud to be the latter.
- How do you balance all of this, man?
The shoes, the wine, you
know, the content constantly.
I mean, your podcasts,
your YouTube channel,
your Instagram, all of your socials.
- Lack of obsession of perfection.
- I got it, yeah, I mean
because so many times
you know, I don't post
something or I delete the video
or I say, I'll wait til I
get the next better photo.
- Look, I'm going through it right now,
it's very clear to me that
Instagram's going through its
like decline of organic reach.
Everybody's feeling it.
And like even I'm like, fuck,
but like I'm pushing through
and like, yeah, lack of perfection.
I just think doing 97 things at an eight
is better than doing one thing at a 10.
Mainly 'cause the math works out.
One thing at a 10 is 10,
90 at eight is eight
hundred, you know, you know.
- How do you decide
what to hop on as well?
Because I noticed you're you're
first on everything, man.
- I read comments.
- so then what happens with the app,
you remember that app that
came out I feel like last year?
It was not Strava, it was another one.
- Oh, Vero?
- Vero, there we go.
I feel, you know, I saw
everything for two weeks
and then nothing.
- That's where I'm really good,
I'm really good at being patient.
Everybody wants to jump on
like, peach is the next thing,
Vero's the next thing,
like everybody's like,
the next thing, the next thing.
I'm not obsessed with the next thing,
I'm obsessed with the right thing
and doing it the best in the right thing.
Yeah man, I pay attention, look,
I'm a creature of the culture
of the attention of everything.
I'm watching, I just watch.
You know, this is the
funniest thing about me,
I talk so much, I interrupt so much,
but I listen, man, how am I
fuckin' first on everything?
'Cause I listen, I listen
with my eyes, right.
I remember this very clearly,
three years ago I'm just
going through the airports,
I'm like why are young women wearing jeans
with tears in them again
like they did in the 90s?
Right?
- Yeah.
- I'm watching. I'm
watching like, I'm watching.
Like, it didn't take me
too long to figure out
like kids were wearing
Champion hoodies or Fila's back
or like, I'm watching, I'm watching.
- Gary.
- Yes?
- I want to say thank you so much man.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- You know, you constantly
inspire me, you're genuine.
- So what's this podcast gonna be about?
- It's about anything
and literally everything.
You know, it's going through my phonebook,
it's me going through my Instagram DMs
and me having all my friends
and cool people in the world on
to chat about literally
anything and everything.
- I love that.
Listen, I'm gonna drop one little thing
that I've been thinking a
lot about over Thanksgiving.
And we talked about it just now.
This is a game of selfish versus selfless.
If you asked me why so much
good is happening for me?
Is I get high on giving to others.
It's like this perpetual machine.
I love admiration,
admiration is only earned.
Nobody sees you the first
time and admires you.
And so there's so many people
that are trying to build personal brands,
trying to like get on.
You have to be obsessed
with every time you post
are you bringing value to everybody
or are you trying to
get something from them?
- Are you giving or taking.
- Are you giving or taking,
and everyone's taking.
It's about how many likes
and followers you get,
that is disproportionately a take game.
That's it, that's why so many
of you are struggling to pop.
Every post is, will this get me,
do you know many attractive women
get frustrated after three posts
and then decide to show flesh again
because the only KPI is likes?
And will say to my face like,
I want to build a fashion brand for women.
And so I'm like take half the likes
and make content for
women, not for pervy dudes.
- And they struggle with that.
- And that's why I want to talk about this
for the last sentence which is like,
are you happy about your
40,000 likes that mean nothing
or do you want the 13,000 likes
that are actually
predicated on your ambition?
Oh wait, you want forty thousand likes
'cause you care about
what other people think
when they see how many likes you got.
Like, we were getting, we
were so deep into a math game.
Do you know how many people
would shit their pants
if tomorrow Instagram decided
to stop showing likes and follows?
It would be the best--
- It would be over.
- It would be the best
thing for the humans.
- Yeah well, I mean, Kanye,
a bunch of people went on,
they went online telling, for Twitter,
Kanye was like, remove
the like and the retweet,
you know, the numbers.
- Yeah, I just, I think
there should be like,
it'd be really cool if
people could live one month
without seeing the metrics,
they'd be stunned by how much
that would impact what they put out.
And that's what's worked for me.
I'm interested in your admiration.
What I love about when I sign sneakers
or when I'm in the airport
is the amount of people
in the last six months
that say to me I never
fan out about anybody
but I needed to come and take a selfie.
- I brought your book when
we first met on my beach show
and I was too nervous to have you sign it.
I was like, I never do this.
- And I'll tell you why.
It's so much more fun to be followed
because someone admires
that you brought them value
than the fact that you can
drop 55 in a basketball game
or the fact that you're a
size zero with a pretty face.
That's just the truth.
I was wondering why it was happening,
it was happening a lot.
Like really famous people are
like freaking out or like,
you could just tell when
somebody was in the scene
all the time, it was just
like, it was happening, right?
And I was like, right.
Because I'm getting admiration
and that is something
everyone should try to do
and I think the reason
is if you make admiration
the North Star you will produce
dramatically better content.
You're not gonna try for a hack.
The reason I was never
in an engagement group
is I don't need the bullshit
metrics, I need admiration.
That doesn't come with
fake fucking followers.
Fake followers can't stop
you in the fucking hallway
to say that you changed their life.
- Fake followers aren't
gonna ask you for a picture.
- They're just not gonna say
that you changed their life.
The reason I do garage sale videos
is because people will
stop me at the airport
and say that 900 bucks they
made during this holiday season
that allowed them to buy
a gift for their daughter
because they fucking sold
shit that was in their closet
mattered to their lives.
Not because I wore a cut-off t-shirt
in a very attractive way.
Seriously, why do you think
celebrities are losing?
What value are they bringing?
You can't be an a-list
Hollywood celebrity anymore and be cool.
Like Angelo Julie is not fucking winning.
Rap hits era is over.
Because they bring nothing to the table.
At least an a-list Instagram celebrity
once in a blue moon may like your comment.
There's at least a
prayer of an engagement,
those fuckers need to learn too.
By the way, quickest hack I'm
going to leave you with this,
if you're fucking trying
to build a big audience
and you are not replying
to the couple of people that
give a fuck about you right now
you're a fucking idiot.
That's how I built myself,
Twitter 2007 to 11,
I replied to everybody.
You're telling me you want a
million people to fuck with you
but you don't have the seven minutes
to say thank you to the
13 comments you got?
You're fucking selfish, dick.
It's a selfless versus selfish game,
99% of people are selfish
which is why 99% of people
will never build an audience.
Simple.
- We're gonna end it right
there, Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
I love you buddy, thank you so much.
(hip hop music)